so I will be flying down to Texas today
and then making the drive into Waco in
preparation for my speech tomorrow at
Baylor a speech that as you heard on the
show yes last week has sparked protests
and petitions and and now after 2000
people signed a petition demanding that
my speech be canceled which thankfully
has not been now the a different group
of students and staff and faculty have
written a letter about about the speech
that makes some pretty wild claims about
me and about what I plan to say so I
want to talk about that in a minute and
I also want to talk about many other
interesting things that have happened
over of the over the weekend that have
nothing to do with me thankfully so
we'll get to all of that but first Hair
Club listen your confidence is very
important it's one of the most important
tools that you can take with you on a
day to day basis is your confidence and
sometimes one little change that one
seemingly little change can make a huge
difference to your confidence and
therefore to your life as a whole and
hair club knows this and they're
inviting you to become part of the hair
club family to see how getting the most
out of your hair can change your life
they understand the emotions that you're
feeling they understand all the
questions that you have that's why
they're there to answer the questions
Hair Club is the leader in total hair
solutions with the legacy of success for
over 40 years they've been doing this
whether you're looking to revitalize the
growth of your own hair to learn more
about the latest methods of hair
replacement a restoration Hair Club has
a team of professionally trained
stylists hair health experts and
consultants who will come up with a plan
that is specific to you so there's no
cookie cutter solutions here this is
specifically gonna be tailored for you
and then you can see for yourself just
how powerful great hair can be so go to
hair club comm slash Walsh today for a
free hair analysis and free take-home
hair kit that's something that usually
would cost you 300 bucks but you could
do it for free free I can't emphasize
that enough all you have to do is type
in hair club hair club comm slash Walsh
wal SH in case you didn't know for a
free hair analysis and free hair kit
hair club club comm slash
Hair Club comm slash Walsh experience
your hair and your life at its best
only with Hair Club I'm certain that
you'll love the club okay so there was
the the petition to thousand signatures
there have been people pulling down
signs at Baylor for my event the local
media called me a theocratic fascist and
and all of this as I think it bears
repeating that all of this is because of
a speech that I plan to give about
Christian values on a Christian campus
and now six hundred students staff and
faculty have written in hand-delivered a
letter to the president of the
university saying now let me pull this
up I'm not gonna read the whole thing
it's pretty long letter detailing my
many high crimes and misdemeanors but in
part this letter which again was given
to the president University says let's
see here
we have learned that Baylor University
has approved the student group Baylor
young Americans for freedom as an
official student group on campus as an
official student group Baylor yaf is
permitted to apply to host events and
speakers in Baylor's facilities and
auditoriums and to apply for funding
through the student government fund on
April 9th
we understand that Baylor yaf has been
approved by the university to host daily
wire commentator and blogger Matt Walsh
who will give a talk on quote the war on
reality why the left has set out to
redefine life gender and marriage in
Baylor's McClinton auditorium the Flyers
for this event which were also approved
by University's Department of Student
Activities contain images that many find
inflammatory associating the LGBTQ
community with totalitarian regimes
mister Walsh is openly critical of LGBTQ
people he also opposes women ministers
and the me2 movement and he believes
that higher education in the United
States is quote overrun by feminists and
nihilus I did say that mr. Walsch
believes that men were put on the earth
to have authority over women and that
women should never be in a position of
authority over men I did not say that
he has well I said part of that but I
won't get to add minute he has stated
that women are very often raunchy
aggressive and sexually a cert
I did say that and he believes that
women athletes have quote literally
dozens of immutable biological
disadvantages in comparison to men I
said that as well perhaps unsurprisingly
mr. Walsh's University sanctioned
appearance on campus has not gone
without criticism blah blah blah okay so
here's the good part says although some
of the undersigned have expressed
concerns about the risks that mr.
Walsh's presence on campus poses for
students emotional psychological and
physical well-being the purpose of this
letter is not a petition to STOP mr.
walsh from visiting Baylor's campus oh
that isn't that nice of them now I asked
for clarification about how exactly my
presence on campus could possibly pose a
physical threat to anyone but myself and
no one was able to explain it that is
that's a pretty pretty serious charge to
make about a person to say that their
very presence in a place could pose a
threat to the physical well-being of
people I would think that you you if you
if you say that if you write it down in
your letter you it should mean something
right you should be able to if I ask you
Oh what do you mean by that you should
be able to say oh well this is what I
mean only I was not able to get an
answer apparently it doesn't mean
anything
it really is ironic isn't it that
they've got thousands of people
protesting me using inflammatory
rhetoric about me yet I make them feel
unsafe it is really amazing the ability
that some people have to make themselves
the victims even as they're ganging up
on one guy and shouting out of their
victims right it's really impressive but
you notice the the really underhanded
tactics here because in this particular
letter they said well yeah I mean look
mr. walsh was a terrible guy is a bigot
he poses a threat to the emotional
physical well-being of students but
we're not saying you should cancel the
speech we're just saying you know he's a
threat to people and oh by the way just
some people who sign the letter think
that he's a threat we're not saying that
officially we're just throwing it out
there as a you know just something to
keep in mind so this is clearly a letter
meant to shut down the speech without
saying shut down the speech right as for
the terrible awful no good very bad
things they quote me as saying well
let's see they say that I'm critical of
LGBTQ people yes I have criticized LGBTQ
people they they're just people aren't
they they're not gods you can criticize
them
I mean we're allowed to [ __ ] I've
criticized a lot of straight people in
my day as well so the very fact that
they that they listed that as a problem
oh he's criticized LGBTQ people people
well of course I have I've criticized a
lot of people including myself you're
not you're not immune from criticism
just because you claim to be a member in
that acronym at least as far as I'm
concerned you're not immune from
criticism
maybe that's the treatment you get
elsewhere in the world but not for me
and that as far as I'm concerned is just
equality right so they say that I oppose
women ministers yes I do
so did st. Paul so I feel like I'm good
in good company at least I should be in
good company on a Christian campus they
say that I oppose the me2 movement yes I
absolutely do with pride they say that
college that I say that colleges are
overrun by feminists and nihilus well
yeah and exhibit a would be the people
who sign this letter they say that I
claimed that men are the head of women
and that women should never be in a
position of authority over men well that
part I didn't say I never said that
there's no scenario where women should
be in the authority of a man that women
should know you know that III clearly
did not say that because that would
obviously mean that I think that there
could never be a woman manager at a job
or something I did not I absolutely did
not say that so that's just false in the
church yeah I don't I I think that men
are supposed to be leadership positions
in the church which is in the Bible and
and they say that I claim that men are
the head of women well no I I didn't
claim that the Bible claims that
multiple times very clearly like in 1st
Corinthians for example it says but I
want you to realize that the head of
every man is Christ and the head of the
woman is man and the head of Christ is
God now this is a Christian school isn't
it so I I'm just paraphrasing first
Corinthians a mine it's odd the fact
that I did that means I'm not welcome on
a Christian campus now we could talk
about what exactly that means I don't
think it means that a woman can never be
in a position Authority and I didn't say
that but I do think it means something
especially as it pertains to the family
the home the church and that's just
right from the Bible they said that that
I said women can often be raunchy and
sexually aggressive
well again I fail to see what's wrong
with my point there meant men can be
that way too but my point in saying that
was that it was to point out that uh
that men are not the only ones and it's
one of my problems with the me2 movement
that it paints this very simplistic
scenario where men are always the sexual
aggressors and women never are but the
point that I made is that women can be
the sexual aggressors and have been many
times look at the public school system
look at teachers in the public school
system going after thirteen-year-old
boys I mean it happens a lot just the
facts and then they said that I said
that women athletes have dozens of
biological disadvantages in comparison
to men yes again absolutely true no
question that's a scientific fact
so do I apologize for saying any of that
no no I don't not even a little bit
would I have phrased it differently if I
could do it over again no I wouldn't
have I would phrase it exactly the same
way if I could those articles they
quoted if I could write them all over
again I would definitely write them
exactly that way in fact I think they
were very well-written articles and I'm
quite proud of them so I'm still coming
anyway I'll see you there well we don't
have a lot of time to spend on this but
I I'm sure you've already seen it and I
can't ignore it because it's just so
excruciating and uncomfortable
and hilarious at the same time I want to
show you I'm here's here's a Oh see if
you haven't seen it yet
AOC talking to a group of mostly black
people a few days ago here watch this
this is what organizing looks like this
is what building power looks like this
is what changing the country looks like
it's when we choose to show up and
occupy the room and talk about the
things that matter most talking about
our future you know Reverend you bring
up a funny anecdote and I'm proud to be
a bartender ain't nothing wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with working
retail folding clothes for other people
to buy there is nothing wrong with
preparing the food that your neighbors
will eat oh oh goodness that is that
took me three days to work up the
courage to watch honestly to watch that
whole clip it took me it took me three
days the second hand embarrassment is so
intense that I couldn't I just couldn't
do it I got to the to the ain't nothing
wrong with that line and I just I had to
turn it off it was too much here's a
good rule of thumb if you never used the
word ain't in conversation which I
guarantee a OC does not but you're
thinking that you would like to you
would like to introduce that word into
your lexicon
well don't debut it in front of a group
of black people or in front of a group
of southern white people because because
then that's going to come across
rightfully so as pure grade-a pandering
which is what that was and you know of
course as far as pandering goes nothing
will ever beat Hillary Clinton in 2008
so let's take a quick trip down memory
lane I don't feel no ways tired
[Applause]
from where I started from nobody told me
that the road would be easy I don't
believe he brought me this far to leave
me someone actually wrote that I don't
feel no ways tired okay so someone wrote
that in Clinton speech for her for her
to read it was written there was a line
think about that that was a line written
on a piece of paper in the speech I
don't feel no ways tired and then and
then Clinton had to go over that and see
that line and say oh yeah they'll love
that no that's that's that's a good one
that's real good my lord but but here's
I think the bigger question if we can if
we look past the the fake accent for a
moment she's saying what a OC is saying
is well there's nothing wrong with
driving a bus or working retail or
working at a restaurant and so on and
and I agree there's nothing wrong with
that but who first of all who ever said
that there is something wrong with that
who's going around saying there's
something wrong with being a bus driver
bus drivers are bad you bus drivers
should be ashamed of yourselves
driving buses I don't think anyone is
saying that I've never heard anyone I've
never heard anyone suggest that there's
something wrong with driving a bus or
working at a restaurant that is just a
giant straw man because I have to
imagine and I could only imagine because
it's not clear from what she said but
that she seems here to be targeting
conservatives who encourage people to
pursue their goals climb the ladder and
and find success that's I I could only
assume that that's that's the point that
she's trying to make and and that
obviously is nonsense it's it's
demeaning to the working class to tell
them that driving buses and working
retail is their place right and their
station in life and that they should
just be satisfied with
now it's fine if somebody is satisfied
with it if somebody is content mning
that and that's what they want to do for
further for a living then great that's
perfectly fine perfectly respectable
awesome you know but there's also
nothing wrong with wanting to climb the
ladder and pursue other opportunities
and find and make more money
and you know there's nothing wrong with
that either either and and messages like
you hear from from a OC accent aside
seem to be very close to saying this is
your place be happy with it
you know because it strikes me that a OC
probably is not going to go to some
ritzy fundraiser in the rich part of New
York or or you know over in Hollywood or
something and and give that speech
certainly not in that accent but she's
not going to give that speech at all so
it seems rather demeaning to me even
again if we put aside the accent that
that's what she that's her message to a
group of minorities I think the message
should be to everybody you know whatever
you're doing for a living it's as long
as it's legal and it's it's it's great
that you're making a living you're
providing for your family we the work
there's nothing wrong with doing a
working-class blue-collar job we do need
people to work in restaurants and drive
buses and do all that kind of stuff
there's also nothing wrong with with
pursuing things beyond that there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
trying to climb the ladder and make more
money be able you there's nothing wrong
with that either and it's good to have
goals see that's the that's the crucial
difference between the message you also
often hear from the left to the working
class and the message you often hear
from the right to the working class
whereas from the left the message to the
working class most of the time seems to
be like this is what you do be happy
with it that's your life whereas from
the right the message is or should be
there's a great thing very respectable
if you want to do something else if you
want to climb you can do that also
all right speaking of of demeaning
pandering type messages I want to look
at I want to look at this Gillette you
know the razor company they've already
embarrassed themselves with that toxic
masculinity add a few months ago and now
Gillette is going back to the self
humiliation well focusing this time on
on women and Gillette wants to trumpet
body positivity so they posted this
picture right here take a look at this
it says and then if you're if you're
listening on soundcloud or something
it's the caption says go out there and
slay the day slay the day which is fine
kind of stupid but fine
but then there's a photo of a of a very
morbidly obese woman in a bikini at the
beach and the message is go out there
and slay the day and then and then they
followed that up with another message
about cell
except in some body positivity and so on
and so forth now just to be clear I
don't think that anyone should hate
themselves no matter their physical
condition I don't think it's okay to
bully overweight people or insult them
or anything like that I do feel bad for
people who who are very overweight
but I also don't think that anorexic
people should hate themselves and I
don't think it's okay to bully anorexic
people and I feel bad for people who are
anorexic and everyone would agree with
that yet everyone would also agree when
it comes to anorexia that we shouldn't
celebrate it and if this was a photo of
a skeletally thin woman with her with
her ribcage prominently on display
looking like she hadn't eaten in three
weeks and it was go out there and slay
the day with her in a bikini then
everyone else everyone would agree that
it's a completely inappropriate and
dangerous advertisement and the outrage
would be palpable from everybody because
it would be an ad that encourages and
celebrates self harm so that's the big
glaring thing that's missing from body
positivity campaigns if you noticed is
that you never see you'll see morbidly
obese people but you never see anorexic
people in the body positivity campaigns
why is that well because we understand
that there's nothing positive about
anorexia
it's a canoe doesn't mean that if you if
you are interacting that you're a bad
person or or anything like that it's
just it's a condition that the afflicted
person needs to find help for and
overcome so that they don't die it's
there they are hurting them there they
are hurting themselves they're killing
themselves it's it and if you care about
someone and you love them you're not
just gonna applaud the fact that they're
interested greater you're gonna
encourage them to get help because you
care about them well the same is true of
morbid obesity a study that was done a
few years ago found that the extremely
obese have a life expectancy that on
average is almost 15 years shorter than
the the standard life expectancy 15
years think about that and that's an
average so it means that there are a lot
of morbidly obese people who die from
complications of obesity you know 20 25
30 years before before the you know
average you know life expectancy for
most people why is that because the
human frame is is is not meant to carry
that kind of weight your bones can't
handle it your organs can't handle it
your heart your lungs an enormous strain
is placed on your entire body by this
extra weight and your body just can't
handle it
think about what it means to be morbidly
obese it means that you're wearing
essentially a 100 pound coat of lard at
all times and that's I'm not being mean
about it that's not an insult it's just
that's the reality and it is absolute
madness to put this forward as a healthy
normal beautiful way to live because
it's not it's deadly and it will kill
you so that's all it should be possible
for us to acknowledge that fact while
also acknowledging that people
legitimately come in different shapes
and sizes and not everyone is capable of
being or desires to be or should desire
to be a bodybuilder or a supermodel you
know it should be possible for us to
acknowledge that it's ok if you don't
have washboard abs it's okay if you have
some Federer in fact now there are some
people that have great ABS just
naturally and we're all very envious of
those people but probably most people
who you look at if they've got the you
know just the that bodybuilder kind of
physique well it could be that they are
bodybuilders or athletes which is great
but if you're just a kind of a normal
person working a normal job and you also
the physique of a bodybuilder probably
means that pretty much you're in your
entire life outside of your work you're
just at the gym which which is excessive
so that's so but we most of us would
acknowledge that right and so then we
move away from portraying women in ads
and TVs as supermodels all the time
now we allow more kind of normal
physiques to be seen and and that's good
I think and I'm totally in favor of that
I also think that what we call
overweight these days can be pretty
absurd for instance I looked at one of
those BMI calculators online recently
not a very scientific way of doing it
but you know one of those find out if
you're fat things and and so I thought
well I don't know maybe let me find out
if I'm fat and it turns out that I am
according to I really am I'm I'm I'm a
fatty I think it said according to this
medical chart that I was looking at with
my height of 6 foot it said that my
healthy weight range is like I don't
know like 160 to 180 or something like
that which I haven't been that light
since probably high school I'd have to
be I'd have to be skin and bones okay as
a six foot tall man to be 160 pounds you
would have to basically be skin and
bones so that struck me as kind of
ridiculous and I think there are
probably a lot of women I think women
have it worse in that regard because
there are a lot of women especially once
they start having kids who are normal
perfectly normal
attractive good-looking women who but if
they look at one of those charts they're
gonna be told that they're fat because
they do have some extra fat on them as
as everyone we all are supposed to have
fat on us right so that's you're
supposed to have some fat and sometimes
if you certainly if you listen to the
way doctors talk about it sometimes or
if you see one of those charts it would
seem as if you're being told you're not
supposed to have any fat on you
whatsoever which would be deadly so we
can all acknowledge that
no problem but that doesn't mean that we
have to then declare that it's great and
awesome and wonderful for a person to be
150 pounds overweight so it's possible
for us to say you know if you're 15
pounds overweight no big deal you know
you're fine but just because we say that
it doesn't mean that well if you add an
extra zero at the end of that that it's
also fine I don't know why what it is in
the society where we seem incapable of
drawing these distinctions and dealing
with these kind of obvious nuances where
everything so it's sort of all or
nothing so we say either we have to fat
shame everybody and and say that you
know you you you have to have a body a
BMI of two or or you're you're you know
you're fat so that's that's one option
or we have to celebrate people who are
you know 5 foot 5 and and 350 pounds
like no there's there's a lot of room in
between there I think that we need to
settle somewhere in between and
certainly if you are 350 pounds and 5
foot whatever that is a a deadly
situation a very unhealthy situation and
so when we encourage it and we applaud
it
we are not helping the people in that
position doesn't see doesn't seem like
the kindest or most generous things the
thing to me there's a reason why I mean
when was the last time you saw an 85
year old morbidly obese person it seems
like you never see those kinds of people
and the reason is that most likely
they're gonna die before that so maybe
think about that next time you're
considering applauding morbid obesity
because what you're applauding for that
person is their own early death all
right let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
let's see here hi Matt as from Ethan
says hi Matt I want to tell you I really
enjoy your podcast and the
thought-provoking subjects you cover
it's unlike anything else on The Daily
wire or anywhere I'm sorry for the flack
you take for trying to get people to
think independently and critically I
think you do a great job now to my
question on your show on Friday you said
that a knowledge of Christian doctrine
Christ's divinity the virgin birth etc
is not innate but must be taught I agree
with that take I also agree that it's
ridiculous to try to convince unbeliev
unbelievers of a certain subject by
using the Bible but then you also said
that knowledge of God of a creator of
some kind is also innate I know I know
most Christians think this but I'm not
sure if I agree if knowledge of God is
innate
if everyone knows it deep down why do a
theists exist and why are there so many
different religions I'm not sure I
follow your logic on this can you
explain further
yeah interesting question thanks for
asking it so when we talk about the
innate knowledge of God we mean that as
you said everybody naturally by their
nature at some level knows that some
sort of higher power higher force exists
clearly they cannot know innately
automatically about the particulars of
Christian doctrine but they can know and
they do know they do sense the basic
truth that god or gods exist so that
that's the idea here now I admit that
there are some challenges to that
viewpoint it does raise questions
questions that Christians I think often
make no attempt to deal with a grapple
with which is maybe a constant theme on
this shows is I like to try and deal
with hard questions that it seems to me
we in the church often avoid or ignore
so on this idea of an innate knowledge
of God here's here's the challenge to
that idea as far as I see it and then
I'll talk about how I deal with that
challenge the basic challenge is this
who we we each as individuals have only
ever experienced the world through our
own minds we have never experienced even
one second of existence in anyone else's
mind that is a huge limitation think
about that limitation I don't think we
think about it enough really what it
means that you've got seven billion
whatever six and half billion people on
the planet right now
and all of them are living their own
lives they've got their own stories
they're experiencing life through their
own minds and all you've only ever
experienced it through this one little
prism in your one little corner of the
world that's a limitation and it means
that everything we assume or declare we
do so mostly by extrapolating from our
own personal experience but I am just
one of the ten billion people who have
existed on earth at some point in
history how can I possibly know what
what what the experience of reality is
like for anyone else just because
something seems obvious or innate to me
how could I know that it's innate to
anybody else there are some say there
are some who say that I can't know that
nobody can know no one can really know
anything we can basically know nothing
because we're so limited and constrained
by our ego by our you know by our
inability to experience anything through
anyone else's lens now I don't go that
far obviously but it's not a crazy
thought I mean it is true again that I
only know what the world is like through
my eyes there are some Christians who
don't take this problem into account at
all I probably have haven't really
thought about it much so they go around
saying that knowledge of Christian
doctrine is innate this is what this
this this is the this is what I've been
here
from from Christians over the last few
days as we've been talking about this
that there are Christians who really
think that belief in the validity of the
Bible is innate and that of course is
just is just silly kind of arrogance
most of the people who have ever existed
on earth have not believed in the Bible
so to claim that it's somehow innate
that we all know deep down that the
Bible is true is just not borne out by
any evidence at all in fact even within
Christianity there is no agreement on
pretty much any Verte we can't agree on
what any verse in the Bible means
there's been disputes and arguments over
all of it but these people who say this
what they really mean is not just that
belief in the Bible is innate but that
their particular interpretation is
innate
they are so wise so holy so in touch
with God that they have tapped into this
innate recognition while almost everyone
else who has ever lived has missed it
which again is just silly arrogance so
that is not any but I would say that the
evidence suggests that knowledge of God
is innate and that we can come to that
conclusion without just assuming that
our own experience of the world is
everyone else's experience because if
that's what you're doing that is invalid
that is illegitimate that's a that's
fallacious you can't do that but we can
observe things outside of ourselves and
come to conclusions that way and so I
come to that conclusion because almost
everyone in the world every civilization
has come up independently with its with
it with a concept of God when the
Europeans came here think about this
when the Europeans came here to the
Americas in the fifteenth and sixteenth
centuries they encountered civilizations
that were completely alien to them
completely disconnected yet they also
discovered intensely religious
civilizations so what are the chances of
that what are the chances if knowledge
of God is not innate what are the
chances that these civilizations
separated by 3,000
miles of ocean up never in contact with
each other at all
exercising no influence over each other
would each come up with that idea
independently randomly what are the
chances of that so we don't need to read
people's minds to see this we can just
look at human history and all
civilizations have turned towards this
unseen power which i think is very
strong evidence both that the power
exists and that knowledge of it is
innate so that's my that's how I would
deal with that let's see here from Scott
says Matt as a fellow bass angler I'm
hoping you'll consider doing a daily
segment on your show about bass fishing
the folks would love it trust me
think about it PS follow up what's your
go-to lure when you can't find and get a
bite on anything else another follow up
do you have an all-time favorite fishing
Lake Scott I would love to do a segment
every day on bass fishing but I think
that I have to take into account what
sort of content other people actually
want to hear and as a general rule I
don't take that into account at all
which maybe you've noticed so I'll just
babble on about whatever I find
interesting but I you know I I do have
to keep that aspect in the back of my
mind I feel like if I did 20 minutes on
bass fishing every day that wouldn't be
good but since you brought it up as to
my go to lure you know well Jay I mean I
guess I don't have anything too creative
it's just a plastic warm Texas rig never
fails well it does fail plenty for me
but it's it's I think it's a pretty
pretty probably my highest batting
average comes on that also I like to
throw a frog if nothing else is hitting
favorite fishing spot I definitely do
have a favorite fishing spot I can't
tell you about it unfortunately because
I don't want anyone to steal my fish and
also because my in-laws live right at
this particular spot they live right on
the lake and I don't want people to go
and start harassing them when they find
out that I'm you know that they're
related to me by law but it's great it's
it's in New England I can tell you that
and it's just it's a small lake with
humongous bass and it's a lot of fun all
right let's see
from Lee this says Matt I'm not going to
insult you or call you a heretic thank
you for that but I will say that you
seem very fond of entertaining ideas
that are not directly explicitly from
the Bible I'm not saying that all such
ideas are automatically wrong but you
also don't know if they're right why not
just stick with the Bible the Bible is
God's infallible word everything we need
is in there you are treading on
dangerous ground that's why people get
so upset with you they aren't attacking
you they are warning you not to go over
a cliff well Lee I think I think some of
these people definitely are attacking me
I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
crying about it but when someone sends
you an all caps email calling you a
heretic and saying you're gonna burn in
hell because you're a fake Christian I
you know I think that's an attack right
we can agree on that but what you just
said is not an attack so and I
appreciate that you you say it's best
not to entertain ideas outside of the
Bible well I have to believe you don't
mean exactly what you just said there
because you can't really mean that you
think we should never have ideas of any
kind that aren't written down in the
Bible because that rules out like 90% of
the ideas you probably have on a daily
basis and it rules out I don't know
things like the idea behind the polio
vaccine and air travel and antibacterial
soap there are a lot of very good ideas
that if people have had that are not
explicitly outlined in the Bible but I'm
going to be fair and I don't want to
strawman you so I'm gonna be fair and
assume that you meant theological ideas
in fact I got an email a few days ago
accusing me of promoting theological
concepts was the phrase they use from
outside the Bible so I'm going to assume
that you meant something similar to that
and as far as that goes yes I do
entertain ideas as as you say
theological ideas that are that are not
explicitly outlined in the Bible and
that's perfectly okay just because
something is an explicitly outlined in
the Bible doesn't mean that it isn't
biblical and I'm gonna give you okay let
me give you like the number one front
and center
ample of this okay let me let me give
you a a theological idea that as a
Christian you probably accept but that
is definitely not explicitly and
directly defined in the Bible the
Trinity okay if you believe that we can
only have ideas theological ideas that
as you say are directly and explicitly
explained in the Bible then you have
absolutely ruled out the Trinity you
can't believe in the Trinity to that
point you have to you have to deny it
the word Trinity is nowhere in the Bible
the concept of the Trinity as we
understand it today
is nowhere explained in anything like
explicit terms the only candidate for an
explicit mention of the Trinity in the
Bible is in as I mentioned this before
the First Epistle of John which in the
KJV does have a pretty direct
illustration of the Trinity but it's
perfect it's pretty roundly recognized
by almost everyone today that that verse
in 1st John is an interpolation was
added in later the earliest manuscripts
of John don't contain it so somebody
added that in and that's why most Bibles
don't contain it so take that out and as
most Bibles have at this point and you
are left inferring the Trinity from
indirect and in explicit references to
it does that mean that the Trinity is
not biblical no doesn't mean that at all
but it does mean that you have to take a
deeper look at the text you can't always
be satisfied with the play it safe
approach and just stick with the things
that are explicitly described the
Trinity is biblical because there are a
lot of verses consistent with it and
that seemed to point to it like in
Matthew 28 you know go therefore and
make disciples of all nations baptizing
them and then the Father and the Son and
the Holy Spirit but there are a lot of
verses like that isn't you the baptism
where you have Jesus and then God the
Father says this is my beloved son and
then the Holy Spirit descends like a
dove so you've got all the persons of
the Trinity there but if you read that
story with the baptism
on your own or if you read that verse
from Matthew 28 on your own without
knowing anything about the Trinity would
you assume on your own from those verses
that the father and the son of the Holy
Spirit are a unity of three persons
sharing the same essence the same nature
and of the same substance I mean what
what ideas like consubstantial spring to
mind from those verses if you hadn't
already been introduced to that concept
well if it would if you on your own
could have come up with that just by
reading the plain language of the text
then you are smarter than about 300
years worth of Christians because it
wasn't until the fourth century that the
Trinity was made official doctrine and
before that there was a debate and there
were different ideas you know
adoptionism docetism Arianism and so on
and i believe again that the trinity is
biblical but it's not biblical in the
sense of being directly completely
explicitly explained in the bible so
things can be biblical without being
directly completely explicitly explained
in the Bible that's my point
the Trinity as an idea came about well I
believe it came about ultimately through
the guidance of the Holy Spirit but in
earthly terms you know if you were
watching it play out back in the in the
early centuries of the church what you
would see would be people developing
this idea because they're trying to make
sense of what they read in the text so
that is a perfectly proper thing for us
to do as Christians that's what I'm
trying to say do you know what else is
not explicitly outlined in the Bible how
about what books should be in the Bible
or that the Bible is the the infallible
Word of God
nowhere in the Bible does the Bible say
that all of the books in the Bible are
the Word of God now there are individual
books that make that claim but those
individual books don't mention the other
books
nowhere in the bible does it say
explicitly that the Gospel of Luke or
first John or the letter to the
Corinthians should be in the Bible
doesn't say that anywhere it's just
there so if you could only believe what
is explicitly outlined in the Bible then
ironically you can't even believe in the
Bible because the Bible itself doesn't
say that in the Bible as I'm sure you
know it's not like Jesus ascended into
heaven and he just tossed down the Bible
hey by the way before I go here you go
catch and he tossed the Bible completely
fully complete and there it was no it
was written over sin sure well for you
if you include if you include the Old
Testament the Bible is written over the
course of many centuries and it was
compiled over the course of a period of
time and there was a debate about which
book should be in the Bible that there's
still debates today Catholics and
Protestants don't agree about some of
the books in the Bible so again I think
your idea of playing it safe actually
kind of destroys everything and I'm a
week ago personal relationship with
Jesus that phrase isn't in the Bible
nowhere does it say anything about
having a personal relationship with
Jesus doesn't say it's not in there
phrase is not in there I mean there are
so many phrases and concepts that that
that we Christians use and talk about
and believe in and that are not
explicitly outlined in the Bible they
are inferred from the text in the Bible
sometimes inferred correctly like the
Trinity and then sometimes people infer
things incorrectly come up with with bad
notions so it seems that God does want
us to use our heads to work through
these ideas and talk about them and
debate them and try to figure them out
that's how the Bible came together in
the first place that's where many of our
doctrines came from and it's a good and
healthy and edifying thing
so I appreciate what you said there Lee
but my point is I guess that if all
Christians throughout history had shared
your attitude then I mean we wouldn't
have I don't know what Christianity
would be today but it wouldn't look
anything like what it looks like all
right um let's see I'll do one more I
wrap this up see I gotta find it was a
good another theological one I've done a
lot of those yeah maybe we'll say that
for later we'll save that for tomorrow
okay how about this from from FK says hi
Matt absolutely love the show I have a
very crucial question I need you to rank
these 90s bands matchbox 20 counting
crows Third Eye Blind Savage Garden that
is a great question and I love all 90s
nostalgia questions I love I don't get
nearly enough of them and so I
appreciate that okay so as to your
question and I did give this some
thought
first of all Savage Garden does not
belong in that list at all so I I'm
sorry I did they got to toss them out
because they had what like one hit
they're not they're not in that that so
they're like a one-hit wonder band right
so I'm gonna take out savage garden and
I'm gonna throw in the Goo Goo Dolls so
I'll put them into that category then
we'll rank them so I'll go four to one
starting at four than going so from from
worst to best
number four I would put Third Eye Blind
they had a lot of hits in the 90s I did
like them in the 90s like every person
did but I find their music kind of
unbearable today if it comes on the
radio or something if I hear it it
doesn't have a lot of staying power so I
got to put them at number four then I'll
go Goo Goo Dolls again plenty of hits a
few songs that you know if you're
walking through staples or something
that comes on the intercom you're gonna
you're gonna say oh wow so goo goo dolls
I remember this song the Goo Goo Dolls
also a great they are a great dentist
waiting room band I always enjoy when
that when one of their songs comes on at
the dentist's office
so I'll put them at number three then
all number two I'll put matchbox 20 and
I'm putting them this high mainly
because
I was in traffic the other day and
someone was was blasting really loud the
song unwell remember that song and I
respected first of all they were
blasting 90 songs proudly at the
intersection and I also enjoyed taking a
trip down memory lane listening to that
song coming from the other person's car
and I think matchbox 20 came out with
several really solid pop rock songs and
they were basically the kings of vh1
back in the 90s basically every other
song on vh1 was a matchbox 20 song for a
good probably 5 or 7 years and then top
of the list I'm gonna put Counting Crows
all of their songs were nonsensical none
of the lyrics of their songs make any
sense whatsoever but they were very good
I think at capturing the mood of the 90s
you know they not not through words but
just the combination of nonsensical
words and the music it captured a mood
and so I liked it and and man I mean
come on mr. Jones all I'm saying is that
if mr. Jones comes on the radio you
don't change it nobody nobody changes it
when mr. Jones comes on everyone goes I
remember that song turn this up and that
to me is the real measure of a 90 song
if whenever you hear it you just you
can't help but sing along I try not to
sing along because my singing voice
causes projectile-vomiting to take place
among those around me but I have the
urge anyway that I have to suppress
whatever that song comes on so that's
how I drank it but thank you so much for
that for that question and I will leave
it there
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
president Trump dumps his head of
Homeland Security
Democrats compete to shore up their wool
credentials and the Israeli election is
in the homestretch that's today on the
bench Shapiro show